I am so excited right now
because we have a huge announcement.
Are you all ready?
Buckle up, and that's a pun intended
because we're taking the Drew Barrymore Show
on the road with the coast to coast
trip along the iconic Route 66.
From California to New York City.
And we've enlisted this very special couple
to help us make this journey.
And here is the story of Karen and Noah Veneklasen.
(applause)
Hi, I'm Karen.
And I'm Noah.
We've got two great kids,
an amazing golden doodle and five chickens.
And we are the founders of Muse and Co. Outdoors,
a sprinter van conversion company in Oakland, California.
In March of 2020, we finished a really large project,
and drew 'em, just absolutely blindsided by the pandemic.
And then all of a sudden, it just hit like a freight train.
We spent three days going, Oh my gosh,
we just had to close everything.
What do we do?
We looked around and realized
we actually had a couple of delivery vans
that just happened to be sprinter vans,
activated the design team remotely and we designed one.
Karen and I took the thing and headed up the post
with the kids.
People would come up to us,
they were flocking into the van
and we realized how much interest there was in these.
And it just absolutely built a love for travel
that both in recreation and business.
I just started to realize how big the world is
and developed the absolute love for it.
Traveling to the next state
can be an eye-opening adventure.
You're seeing something new that you've never seen before.
And that to me is really the power of the travel experience.
We are so unbelievably excited to be
heading out on the road for you.
And can't wait to see you in a few days.
(audience applause and cheering)
Here they are, it's Karen and Noah,
They're joining us before they hit the road.
Hi, guys!
Hi Drew, nice to meet you.
Oh, thank you guys so much for doing this with us.
I am just so glad that you guys are representing that
lifestyle and talking about the whimsy and the wonder
of how extraordinary life in this sprinter van can be.
It is, it's limitless, Drew you know,
it's so amazing just to pull in anywhere you want.
You're not even bound by campgrounds,
you just kind of fall in wherever you want.
It's amazing.
Where are you guys now and when do you leave?
Yeah, so greetings from Oakland, California.
That's where we are from, that's where the company is.
We're leaving after this, Drew,
we are getting on the road
as soon as we hang up with you.
We are quite literally heading off across the country.
We will see you in nine days.
I'm excited you're about to hit the road.
Karen, who will you be meeting along the way?
We are going to be doing a Barrymore tour,
it's a surprise location, I'm not gonna give it away
but I will say, it might be just a tad scary
but it might also be amazing.
I'm intrigue.
I am too, believe me.
We're gonna be meeting some really inspiring Drew gooder.
And then of course, we're gonna be checking in
with a small business owner
and celebrating the amazing job that they've done
keeping themselves and their employees afloat
during this whole pandemic, and we're gonna do more.
We'll share it all with you when we get there.
Well, over the next nine days, we're gonna be with you,
checking in as you make your way here to the show
in New York.
(applause)
That's right.
That's the end destination, I'll be here with open arms.
If you spot the Drew Van in your town,
be sure to take a photo
and send it to the show or post it on social media.
You just might see your picture on the air.
That's right, 'cause we're gonna show
some of these pictures.
I'm gonna feature some on my social media,
by the way, did you guys get some of the
Drew's News stickers too, do you have those?
Yeah, we did.
And they're already getting stuck.
Perfect
All over for people to find.
I love seeing stickers and I feel like it's a lost art.
So we printed a bunch of Drew's News stickers.
So if you see those around, tag us too.
All right, Karen and Noah, Veneklasen, safe travels
with you on the road, we will be here waiting
but checking in with you all along the way.
And seriously, if you spot that Drew Van, let us know.
Thank you Drew, we're so excited to get there.
Thank you Noah and Karen.
(uplifting music)